um so good afternoon elected members
staff and anyone who is watching in our
community today I will just open our
meeting or rejoin our meeting for Monday
the 25th of May are there any apologies
great no apologies move to the interest
register as you all well know that if
your interests we just innate updaters
please make contact with our
administrative team and they will ensure
that that gets done so we'll move to
item number four on our countdown
commencing meeting which is to adopt the
minutes excuse me time I'm just
switching between screens here so I'm
heavy move close to you
Thank You councillor Sophie anyone hit a
sneak in those Thank You councillor ever
any discussions or questions okay we'll
have our first attempt at hitting our
buttons on the participant screens all
those in favor so at the moment
councillors I have nine people ten in
these thirteen elected members
I had Lindsay Emmett who was voted
counselor scalped and counselor kids
chanson a cricket still waiting on your
votes the ones up top if you go to
participants the email was seen to help
go to participants counselor cricket and
you'll see that we have a nice or no
option and Mia today we I now have 11 so
I'm waiting on two more
I now have 12 I'm waiting on one more
computer you can do it I've done it
a counselor kick I don't see your vote
recorded I was probably one of the first
to present I found the box is Tecton
year screen box and I've pressed that
I've done it again sit there it is now
Thank You counsel
we have 30 nieces so a big mushroom we
will pass thank you
in then I'll move back obviously to the
next item of our agenda packing
exceptions policy and now here to speak
to it so I'll pass it over to you thank
you hi everyone the report promised that
I'll take it as being received and it's
been to the regulatory committee and
then it's come forward to you guys to
the final vote on that YouTube madam
chair that oh you're muted sorry that
was my fault
my sincere apologies and we've done a
bit of work on this council is you know
in so I'll ask if there's any questions
around this and I think I have one from
counselor Arnold counselor Pottinger
okay I'll just see option a means
there's pretty much the status quo
my preferred option is probably option B
to be fear with them no no ongoing
exemptions after you leave Council and
I've been referred to have won one out
if you like that you could actually move
between vehicles because some
more than one vehicle that we use on a
regular basis as opposed to getting to
the to the two options are quite close
but I my preferred option if I the truth
between the two would be option B John
thank you Tony
yeah I'm also an agreement with option B
looking at looking at this from a just a
rational point of view I I really can't
understand why we would persist with
option A I can't see any good reason for
that the idea of a laminated card
there could be transferred vehicle makes
a lot of sense and just having that one
so whatever vehicle you jump in you grab
that with your council medallion thing
in your way and you do it that way the
only thing I would like to add would be
that we have a lot of joint committees
with other councils especially with Gore
and I know that councillors go to GWAR
and have to try and find parks around
their council chamber and vice versa
they probably come to Invercargill more
so I would like look at the possibility
of maybe some issuing cards that could
be shared that way and then we would get
over that problem yeah I think that
could be done by the city maybe but I
would actually move now for option B I
thank you Pottinger
do ibis you can do that i'll see
kinetically okay I've got count some
o'clock waving his hand so to speak
count some a Clark crackit Lois in kit
and I'll take that motion being moved by
council Pottinger and seconded by
Councillor Clark
no I just had a side issue we've all
probably received an email from Rodney
tribe and he raised an interesting issue
which I'm not
so some of the longest-serving councils
maybe does does the parking exemption in
any way affect our remuneration
authority sealing on cap so is that a
sort of a a benefit that we give it
should be should be recognized by the
authority or is that separate to that
and the second thing is the I just
wanted to reinforce what the others to
see the common favor of that option
Thank You councillor I should say a
council tax question before I move to
councilor cricket Louis any council of
heat madam chair I know this is an issue
that must have foster looked at earlier
in the year when this paper first came
up I believe that the amount that we are
considering is doesn't really meet a
threshold of concern to the remuneration
Authority I'll leave it there unless he
signals to me but he had heard other
ones and I think you can see that no my
advice to you is correct
thank you thank you clear council
Cricket Council and Louis inning
councillor kit in the order I think huge
here I would agree with moving forward
with option B and also with the addition
of the exemptions for GDC and SDC
because like councillor prodigy had said
I mean I've experienced it with wasting
it in particular we do have a lot of or
we do have a lot of people popping in
and out for council business I think
it's also important to note because
councillor Arnold and council Opatija
had both mentioned about a potential
laminated card or whatever that just
bounces between whichever vehicles you
use that we're actually quite behind
compared to the rest of the country in
terms of how we actually meter our
parking and our parking establishments
and parking buildings and also just
generally street parking we've got the
old lollipops which literally I found
not very many places in the country
these days so at some point we should be
considering to move to them plate
recognition technology
at that point we would register our
vehicles and it would be done by this
visual you own rather than having to
fish around with a laminated card so I
I'm sure that that's that sort of
horizons I know we've talked about it a
couple of times but I think it would be
worth noting or asking for a report on
win or at least an update of when we can
expect to consider what we're doing with
our streetscape infrastructure street
parking in parking buildings Thank You
Council but I'd be quite happy to go to
option B and I think is probably the
most political correct one to do in this
these days of hardship if we'd gone to a
I'm a welcome stain to get in close to
the to the hedgerow would have got a
free one anyway they were end but Sydney
I'm quite here against option B Thanks
it would be easy enough to display
either sorry easy enough for this play
one card they senior citizens do it all
the disabilities have a card and which
can be altered from car to car if you're
going out with mrs. a disability person
you in your own car you can take their
car and pack it or put it on your
windscreen or whatever so it's there for
inspectors to see enough done yes thank
you I share that one of the workshops
possibly in November that the two car to
card system has worked well in the past
I made comment about the removable
dashboard like the total mobility you
can remove one to the other car I have
heard up country where they've had it
and kids have been using the appearance
counsellors cards by just looking at the
other dad's car mom's car and using it
so due to my tip everyone honest I think
you should have one for each car if you
have two cars and have the registration
on both them and it does work in white
I'll be going for the status quo
thank you my question sorry is to either
Ellie or maybe mr. Foster now that he's
here and welcome mr. Foster is just how
much of money obviously it costs for the
councillors elected members to have the
parking exemption in the city for for
elected members what does it cost like
for the council business
you
I think it's probably best if Elly
answers us we've got the numbers Ellie
all right no I don't have what what the
cost would be get in and it would be
harder to tell positives Sukesh like the
meters are cash and not comments or
voices this noise I was just wondering
if he was an epitope from the councilors
not to have the parking exception at all
I'm I'm tariff like I could just it
Ellie's comments thanks Darren I'm just
remembering that the exemption is
applied only when on official council
business so you would expect the numbers
to be relatively low so I can I've asked
my question unsatisfied I'll just go
back through the options and the
recommendations on the table we have a
mover for option B in the Sikandar for
option B option B is clear in the report
the mayor and councillors to be
allocated one parking exemption which
would provide free parking it at any
council provided car park provided that
the vehicle is parked legally of course
it continues on with the bluff community
board and also that we would not be
eligible for a parking exemption when we
leave office the report is here we've
got a mover and seconder sort of puppet
motion all those in favor if you just
want to please tick yes
okay I have 10 votes for you so I'm
going to clear all and ask those against
to vote
you
at councillors I've got two against
could you just raise your hand so I can
see who there is because I think we are
missing a vote
counselors I get the feeling that this
isn't working it's very confusing I've
got people pushing buttons putting up
their hands so I'm gonna I want sick
sorry counselor Arnold you get a clear
majority yeah yes we hands but it
doesn't help if we called for division I
can't see who's voting you're doing what
Siddeley so I'm just gonna clear we have
a majority in their promotion obviously
would pass but I just don't think that
this is actually working it's a cheer
I'm struggling to see everybody and it's
taking a lot longer so I'm gonna go back
to that end up for now just so we can
get through this and then we'll go from
there
sorry staff I know he's been a lot of
effort put into this just heaven it's
not working Tony I crashed like a bit of
crushed okay
thank you I say Council but can you
clarify did you guys I would vote for
option B I can see this just as going
round around in circles from the elected
members through the workshop the
preferred option in was a and now
everyone's taking on about turn
councillor kit I I think it's really
disrespectful popping in like that we
have read the report your colleagues
have read through the same information
we've taken a vote today the vote was
for option B for one pass predicted
members not to that's not going around
in circles at all this is the democracy
and unfortunately your motion has fell
short or you've lost that so I
respectfully I'd like to move on from me
so the next item on the agenda would
that motion being passed is to move to
the proposed name train
in relation to the subdivision of 162
Peterson men I'm sure if you're
comfortable here we does speak to us
report thanks Darren sorry sir he's just
stolen it from me on to you think you
could be was this report relates to the
proposed name change a small subdivision
that went to the regulatory committee
the original subdivision was consented
in 2009 but was never undertaken by the
thin developer a new developer is now
wanting to realize the subdivision and
has put forward a name change I take the
reporters being read and happy to take
any questions Thank You Darren are
questions from counselors soper
counselor in counselor Monroe sorry
madam Chia wasn't a question I was going
to move that I thought there were no
other questions I was going to move and
I was going to see can madam Jim and so
with all that moved and seeking the
motions on the floor I'll put the motion
all those in favor please just raise
your right hand against
motion carries thank you moving to item
number seven on our agenda today which
is the possible governance structure I'm
I take it that everyone has read the
report I would like to let you know that
it has been brought to my attention by
the seee that we need some technical
issues covered around this particular
report a Council of Committee or a
committee of Council does not have any
men date to change committees and this
must be done in a full council for
council level we has worship would cheer
and we would go through the same process
obviously with the report so if if
everyone is happy we can call an
extraordinary meeting this Thursday so
there is a full council in a council
meeting in the Civic we are able to look
at this particular report may be the
most madam chair Thank You councillor
Soper anyone happy to seek in there
thank you I'll second it
thanks mr. I'm sorry to see mr. Lewis is
the any questions or discussion around
me I needed timing in the day we have
the e or T meeting that he live in a
clock later than that would suit me
better because I have a business
appointment around about that time also
thank you I'll just clear madam chair
councils and usually meets at 3:00 p.m.
I would suggest to you that 3:00 p.m.
would be an appropriate time okay 3 p.m.
on Thursday and in the Civic Theater so
that there is plenty of room for distant
scenes of those who wish to attend and
listen if anybody wishes to join by zoom
we can provide that via a large screen
thank you very much no other discussion
or questions around me
our most emotion that we have an
extraordinary meeting on Thursday at 3
o'clock I should discuss this particular
report the way we are following
obviously the right rules around any
governance change if this should be a
governance change etc etc and that will
be done on Thursday in a full council
meeting all those in favor just give me
a wave thank you against carries thank
you in the last report on the agenda
today is the next steps for the souther
Museum and Art Gallery and clear will
speak to that report thank you madam
chair look the the council heads there's
a number of steps it out and that report
and the the past the past history in
relation to it I think what is front of
mind is that the Swank trust board has
endorsed the proposal to transfer
governance of the museum to endure
Carroll City as have Safin district and
gore district originally you were given
advise that it was unlikely that you
needed to consult with the community but
you were planning to consult on an
annual plan and so the suggestion at
that stage was why not put it in the
annual plan as we know from previous
experience that the museum instead of a
heart of many in the public you chose
very good reason not to consult on an
annual plan and asked what does that
mean for the museum I'm putting that
question back to you in the sense of
giving you some options that you could
either determine that further
consultation is necessary based on the
sort of feedback that you've had from
the communities that you work with them
or you might say that limited engagement
with friends
the museum who have been vocal about
their views on the museum and the past
and engagement with Erie would be
appropriate and that you receive that
feedback before you make a final
decision or you might decide that no
further consultation or engagement is
necessary that step is a step that you
need to determine the answer to before I
think it is reasonable to indicate the
you've made a decision and you're going
to then ask your partner local
authorities to request via trustees
their representatives to work with the
Smeg trust board to modify the Smeg
trustee to introduce a skills-based
forward to be entrusted with the
guardianship and ownership of the
collection I think you should also ask
reti we be recognized as partners in
that modified trustee and I noted when
going through the historic resolutions
that all the resolutions from last year
that there was a resolution from
September last year proposing the
disestablishment of us make trust and as
these things have moved on it would be
appropriate to revoke that resolution so
there it is in front of you I'm happy to
answer any questions are questions
councillors councillor are not in my
view I'm sort of thinking that we
probably don't need to go out to
consultation all the interest I ever
hear about is just when the museum's
going to open or close not actually the
governance so I think to be honest as
much as people want to know about it I
think they already know about it so I'd
be quite happy to move this forward
without going pick up the public
consultation Anna Clark if I fully
support that at all
I think that community are wanting to
get some traction on winning museums
going and what that's going to look
forward to governance issues
really a segregation I agree with Ellen
the weight though in for us to do no
further consultation but as cleared
quite rightly says once we get to stage
of setting up a new trustee that's when
you bring in some strategic partners
around me and others I think you can
select a counselor so per capsule of
Pottenger thank you madam chair I just
want to say I'm I'm quite happy that we
don't need to go to Constance
consultation even the suggestion of the
limited consultation it's my
understanding we have been consulted in
Friends of the museum already ribs in
from the transport is a ze way so I feel
the limited consultations already
unnecessary because they have had the
book and I would just like to comment
that on the introduction of a
skills-based board I would see the
skills of an EVA witness being
absolutely relevant to a skills-based
board we would want someone on the
skills-based board who has particular
expertise in the care of Tonga and I I
believe that even while I agree with the
request of recognizing the partnership I
also believe that it would be essential
on a skills-based forward to have a
reserved slot for someone with expertise
in that particular area
I think you cancellous okay I can tell
you that the museum Trust Board is
looking at how they see these
skills-based boards being made up for
the collection so I'm just referring to
the collection in that we have
absolutely made it clear that is it's
just a standard that we would be
participating in every one of those
discussions is I would expect it to be
done
in a council level also and I think
because they are represented represented
we had previously made it clear if this
helps that the advisory committee
there is an advisory board II we
advisory board to Smeg would stay with
the new board or the new make up so
they're absolutely clarifies the we as a
partner which is it's critical
especially when you're referring to our
collection I come from a place of
frustration after having the South of
Museum Trust Board make it very clear
what they felt should happen and we've
waited so long for this decision to be
made and I think like many people just
want to get on with it and get it done
so I absolutely support the move to not
consult on the governance but very very
strongly we can mean there is some
consultation done around the collection
I think that's going to be the next
would have to face counselor loud blow
in putting John no no I'm fine thanks
chief counsel appalling Joe
yeah thanks Tony absolutely moved
forward with the skills-based board I
think it is our call and it expedites
this whole process and the critical
thing is with a skills-based board
hopefully they are entrusted to make
calls on the collection because if we're
going forward to a storage facility I
believe there's a lot of stuff in that
collection that perhaps we do not need
and it's evolved over years so you know
I welcome the skill space forward to
actually look at the collection we may
need new stuff but to look at the
current stuff we have maybe interpreting
their role wrong but I imagine the board
would engage suitable people to do that
Thank You counsel appalling Joe and I
can add to that from this as this make
chair that we've also made a
recommendation that no elected members
be on that board either that it is very
much skill based and not politically
driven and I think that's the best
decision and to move forward for the
sake of the collection I
counselor up pigs thanks Tony
yeah I'm happy to go forward with
without consultation on this one I think
we have done a lot of consultation
around museum issues already and I think
that with this being really just
solidifying the fact that the council is
going to manage the museum which it
actually all essentially already does it
doesn't really seem like that much of a
change the question I have is in the
next recommendation that says the
council work with its local partner
authorities I just wondered whether we
could add into this local authorities
and the Southland Regional Heritage
Committee and I realized that they are
the same thing essentially because the
regional Heritage Committee is made up
of representatives from the local
authorities but the regional Heritage
Committee is the committee that receives
the Heritage Fund and distributes the
money to smeg on behalf of that fund and
so I think it's important that that part
of the conversation in councilor Lewis
was with me at a meeting with him on
Friday and it was really clear that
there's a bit of uncertainty in terms of
the regional Heritage Committee about
where their rollers and whether how they
can get and be part of the conversation
so I think it would be great if we could
initiate that and include them in that
conversation
I think beaks and councillors okay
thanks madam chair if there was no one
else to speak I was going to say I'm
happy to move the recommendations with
the addition of the words just suggested
and the appropriate recommendation I
think it was important to himself and
regional here at which committee kitchen
Thank You council clarify are the
recommendations are that the report
mixtapes make they received and the
council note in thanks make trust board
for the endorsement of the proposal to
transfer governance and management of
the activity of the museum
according to a core Department of in the
Carroll City Council aims that council
determines further consultation is not
necessary obviously that comes to work
with its partner local authorities in
request the Smeg trust or to modify the
Smeg trust deed so is it here that you
would like that addition put before is
after local authorities yes and the
Southland regional Heritage Committee
local authorities even myself okay so
are we I'm looking for Michelle I think
taking minutes and we got there I mean
mentally Michelle she's not in your head
great and obviously that council request
here we are recognized as partners I'd
like to move that we take the request
out here we are partners anyway so
council a recognize a we is our partners
and everyone chair can I just can I
explain that the trustee is not your
deed to alter and so you need to request
the Smith trustees to recognize that
that's why they're requesters the year
that makes sense thank you clear in the
council revoked the resolution from 24
September 2019 relating to the
disestablishment of the Smeg trust today
it's been moved to I have a seconder
Thank You councillor Muenster and just a
question clear before we go out what
happens now after we've removed this
resolution in relation to the museum
council takes back the activity we've
also got a development that we need to
look at I'm wondering if we can actually
put a wee bit more into this particular
report and add some recommendations
around getting a project team together
for the redevelopment of the museum and
just getting away bit more momentum
around this any whatever I'm fortunately
madam chair there is nothing in the
report relation to redevelopment so
effectively you have nothing to base any
decisions on you could ask for
further report setting out the steps for
redevelopment specifically in relation
to the question about what happens next
is that I will communicate with Gore and
Southland and ask that they talk with
their trustees their counsel or trustees
and that we meet with the Smeg transport
to get that moving for the change to be
modified and I will also ask and it's
not only recommendations but I will also
ask for to negotiate a transfer a date
with the with the cement trust okay I
would like to add a recommendation if
the mover and seconder would commit to
that to have another report brought back
to Council to determine the next steps
forward around the redevelopment of Smeg
do I have a seconder or sorry the mover
and seconder happy to do that yes it's
great councillor Craig did you have a
question
I was just sticking doing it if you were
going to put it as a supplementary okay
that's motion to the to the
recommendations please Michelle I've got
an idea
so with all of those recommendations now
on the table
I'll put back to the vote all those in
favor say aye
against great things counselors dick
motions carried and that is the end of
our meeting this afternoon I'm happy to
move into public excluded if I have a
second over there and it's just giving
me away hands up so I'm just gonna check
out if she wants us to do something I'm
just letting you know that we are
currently live streaming so if I'll let
you move into public excluded I'm just
signaling to you that I will need you to
wait for a little bit once that occurs
thank you everybody who's attending the
meeting today my livestream think his
staff and elected members I'm happy to
move we move into public why did I have
a seconder all those in favor all I was
against Thank You counselors